I'm shameik Moore I'm Jack Johnson and
I've voiced Mouse Morales and I voiced
Peter Parker in spider-man into the
spider face to hold you over until the
marvel spiderman game watch brought you
a sneak peek from our upcoming movie I
do get one of those beautiful red ps4's
though right in your universe there's
only one spider-man but there's another
universe
like me spider-verse is the first movie
about a biracial superhero Wow miles has
got to learn from the more experienced
spider people so you want to learn to be
spider-man no I have to learn to be
spider-man one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you this
film has crazy cool action from the
beginning this is gonna take spider-man
to a whole new level
[Music]
in your universe there's only one
spider-man but there's another universe
it looks the sounds like yours but it's
not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you're like me how
I know it's complicated we want to know
what happened to you
I can teach you to be spider-man how am
I supposed to save the whole world you
can't think about saving the world you
have to think about saving one person
look miles what makes you different
that's what makes you spider-man
[Music]
because see the sparking it's amazing
whatever you choose to do with it you'll
be great
I love you mom's dad I love you
economy's time to swing just like I
talked when did you teach me that I
didn't it's a little joke for team
building hey guys I'm Gwen Stacy come on
hey everybody its Charlie we got a new
trailer for spider-man into the spider
verse let's break it down like they said
they released this because spider-man
ps4 just came out I'm still doing the
giveaway for copies of the game all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this but I love this shout out from
shamekh more about the red console that
they're selling is the tie-in it looks
awesome if you don't already own a ps4
and you really like spider-man stuff and
you don't mind spending the extra money
to get it then sure go for it
but within the footage they sort of
explain a little bit more about the
story and why they're having so many
different spider-man from the multiverse
it's not so much about just throwing
everything at you all at once because
there are a bunch of different versions
that they've confirmed that I'll talk
about in a second it's more about them
mentoring Miles Morales as he slowly
learns to be another member of the
spider family so for the most part you
see him with the Jake Johnson Peter
Parker like the 40-something I think he
said he's supposed to be in his mid 40s
during the course of this movie but the
interesting thing is is that we get a
bunch of new shots of the ultimate Green
Goblin in that fight with the other
version of Peter Parker when he saves
him and he says you're just like me kid
Peter's voice sounds totally different
so that might be another version of
Peter that just wears a very similar
classic looking costume most of you have
probably guessed that the reason for
including so many versions of Peter like
not just this one Jake Johnson Peter but
other versions of Peter are so that you
can kill one of them off it can be
really shocking but you don't have to
lose all the versions of Peter it's
probably just the Peter from miles is
earth which I'm guessing is gonna be
earth 16:10 just because that's the
ultimate earth within the Marvel Comics
universe so we'll see they'll probably
Easter eggs for The Ultimates universe
the other versions that they've
confirmed are Nicolas Cage playing
spider-man noir which I think is totally
appropriate
John Mulaney the comedian
playing spider-ham which i think is
hilarious they're doing full-blown
spider-ham and obviously most of you
already know that Hailee Steinfeld is
playing spider-gwen
now even though they're doing all these
different versions of spider-man from
the multiverse some of them get more
screen time than others spider-gwen is a
main character she's another person on
this Ultimates earth so she'll probably
be swinging around with Miles and any
sequels that come along but I think the
idea is is that Peter slowly transitions
away so that when we get to spider-man
into the spider verse 2 he's not around
to help them out like they have to be
full-blown spider people by themselves
oh the gwen stacy looks like she has her
[ __ ] together we get a few more shots of
miles chasing after his uncle the
prowler he probably doesn't know that
he's the prowler here so they'll
probably have an awesome mass crypt
moment where miles takes him down rips
the mask off and finds out that it's his
uncle remember that's donald glover
during spiderman homecoming he's not
voicing this character though so the
person that's doing his uncle is
somebody totally different totally
taking the new comic book II looking
animation style where the word bubbles
will come up to illustrate the action
like when the car screeches you see the
screech illustration another shot of him
in Peters lair with the different
versions of the costume this one on the
left is the electro proof suit the one
in the middle is the classic suit and
the one on the right is the secret war
suit not to be confused with the black
secret Wars as in plural costume which
is a totally different comic book event
but anything you may have noticed here -
when Peter is training him in the
homemade version of the classic suit
Peter's only wearing the top in the mask
so he's running around in regular pants
even when they're swinging in the forest
here probably so little kids can tell
them apart when they're in a really big
action scene and moving really fast
on-screen because both their costumes do
look kind of similar it's one of those
things where you have a big CG action
scene in a live-action movie and people
are shooting at each other with like
lasers or energy beams and they make
them different colors so that real
little kids or dumb people can just tell
who's shooting it who couple more scenes
the spider-gwen swinging around in the
city okay come on guys there's the
comic-con joke but it's not in this
version of the trailer what's comic-con
oh you'll understand we'll explain later
reminder that this movie's coming out at
Christmas so that by the time we sit
down to watch this we'll have already
seen our Captain Marvel trailer we'll
have already gotten the title for
Avengers 4 maybe even a teaser for that
in because this is Christmas the very
end of the year they might also attach
an official teaser for spider-man far
from home that finishes shooting in the
next month or so they should have time
to cobble together some form of teaser
now probably gonna cut it in a way that
doesn't let you know where it is in the
timeline so that it's not spoilery for
Avengers 4 but I've already done a
couple videos about that explaining
where it's supposed to be I'll link that
at the end of this but leave all your
spiderman video requests in the comments
below I'll be doing some new spider-man
ps4 soon too talking about post credits
and big twists and the big scenes Deacon
Herbert congratulations you're the
latest giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my youtube channel there'll be a new
round when I post new Marvel which
should be in the next day or two click
here to watch that new spider-man far
from home Ironman scene and you can
click here for my non-spoilery
spider-man ps4 review thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]